another element of propaganda that we're
hearing from the anti-choice right in
the wake of this leaked decision from
the supreme court that is believed will
overturn roe v wade and planned
parenthood v casey essentially
eliminating the general
understood federal right to an abortion
in most cases for women one of the
things we're hearing from the right is
that this isn't going to go any further
it shouldn't be interpreted that this
change to precedent
ending abortion rights as a federal
issue
should connect to absolutely any other
issue now i don't believe that for a
second and in fact yesterday i tweeted
quote some of the people against
abortion are also against gay marriage
they're against gay adoption they're
against interracial marriage they're
against divorce
some are in favor of it being legal to
fire people for their
sexual orientation or gender identity
which is already legal in many states
this won't stop here for sure there are
more people coming around to this
perspective there's a very good article
in esquire written by charlie pierce
called they're coming for griswold and
obergefell and lawrence and loving and
these are decisions that relate to gay
marriage and interracial marriage and
other things and he says don't for a
second believe what alito put in that um
uh or rather this this is from um i'm
sorry this is from anthony scalia we
emphasize our decision concerns the
constitutional
right to abort hold on who wrote this
you want to see this is a reassurance ah
this is from alito we emphasize our
decision concerns the constitutional
right to abortion and no other right
nothing in this opinion should be
understood to cast doubt on precedents
that do not concern abortion and charlie
pierce writes god above what a croc
they're coming for griswold and for
obergefell and for lawrence and for
loving for all i know
there is no reason to believe that
they're not coming for those things and
why do i say that well i mean just look
just just look at this
these are justices all of them alito
barrett gorsuch kavanaugh we looked at
their confirmation hearings yesterday
and when they were asked about roe v
wade they said listen
they do their standard thing i i can't
prejudge i might be in a situation where
i have to you know all that stuff but
but
i respect precedent and yet here they
are all voting to overturn precedent we
can't trust them as far as we can throw
them and we're already starting to see
an inkling of this among the right one
such example is this guy charlie kirk
who said
if we can get roe v wade overturned
anything is possible you don't stop
after a major win you try to get another
one
hello everybody welcome back email us
your thoughts freedom at charlie
kirk.com i have so many other thoughts
to kind of unpack here but i want to
kind of get to one in particular which
is
if we're trying to save the country
which we are
and we're looking at
repealing roe vs wade it changes the
entire game
they'll be obviously extraordinary
blowbic black on this unlike anything i
think we've ever seen but this takes
courage simple courage by the five
justices if they do
what they're signaling and that's
something that's in short supply right
now from our leaders
it's kind of like oil coming above
surface it's a sign that there's likely
more below
boy is courage in short supply but i
think there's more than we put we even
can put our eyes on right now and if we
can get roe versus wade overturned
anything is possible
i want to tell you guys about hillsdale
college yeah so i don't care about
hillsdale college but
uh
this is not going to be the end
and uh it could be
contraception as part of obamacare that
they go for
you know when we say interracial
marriage i think that that's pretty far
down the line i don't i don't think that
that's next but gay marriage is is a
reasonable target contraception is a
reasonable target
uh a lot of these things are going to be
targets when you get your big i mean
think back think back to maybe one of
the greatest basketball teams in history
the chicago bulls
of the 1990s you know they won those
first three championships and then
jordan retired and then it was like this
is as far as we go even though we're the
best
but they didn't end there they had to
come back and keep going and they got
three more and i don't find anything
equivalent morally between people like
charlie kirk and the great jordan and
scottie pippen arables of the 1990s but
in all seriousness you don't stop after
you get a major win you actually keep
going and that's very very scary stuff
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below